ich drücke einfach nur einmal und der
rest wird jetzt von selbst gemacht ich
werde jetzt hoch geschleudert wie
sonstwas kommen jetzt in den clown
wieder rein
zack bin da drin durch meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen zurück zu
einer weiteren mod vorstellung und zwar
einer clown modifikation was mich jetzt
mal habe ich diese komische bewegung
ausmacht und zwar ich habe mir gedacht
du hast so lange keine mehr hochgeladen
macht doch einfach mal wieder weil es
echt oft gefordert wurde dass ich mal
wieder herstellen
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht okay was
gibt es also für mods die ich eventuell
vorgestellt haben die euch wenn du noch
überraschen werden und da bin ich auf
eine cloning klo cloning mord denkt wink
mordkomplott ich glaube ja so sind mäßig
so wenn etwas synchrones oder
symmetrisch es ist ja gleich deswegen
oder gleiche kurven synchron symmetrisch
ist eigentlich wieder gleich halt
bedeutet das und ich nenne sie einfach
kleinwort weil klonen versteht jeder
unsere nachbarn jedenfalls edith
eingefangen direkt an und erkläre ich
erst mal ganz kurz die sachen wir
brauchen zwar brauchen wir hüllen
speicher am besten 1 234 so viel machen
wie ihr wollt am besten ich will jetzt
einfach zwei oder drei machen
dafür brauchen wir obsidian hier 40
jahren glasscheiben ein eisen blog eine
gewichtete druckplatte ihn schwer also
nicht diese goldenen leicht und einen
sinken was ist der sinn kern luca der
sinkende müsst euch nämlich zuerst
erstmal machen und zwar wird er so
gemacht also der ist echt sehr sehr
teuer braucht dafür ein lapislazuli
block 2 tages lichtsensoren zwei netten
ever quartz thailänder perle im redstone
block und zweitmarkt also der ist schon
schwer zu machen wenn man jetzt nicht
gerade hexe gespielt
damit kommt man halt diesen sinkt in
diesem sinn kann braucht man für
höhen speicher füllen konstrukteur und
fürs laufbahn braucht man ihn nicht so
kommen erst mal zum müll constructor und
zwar ist das halten konnte
konstrukteur sag ich mal konstrukteur
wir wollen neben deutschen bleiben und
zwar eher konstruiert der quasi diese
hülle also euren trier euren clown
unterhöhlen speicher der speicher diese
teuren clown
also wer macht das ganze noch mal mit
mengen die mitte rutschen ich habe das
gefühl dass ich seit dem hekla der
speicher teure klone
dieses macht man so immer wieder dieses
diesen constructor macht man so einen
mann wieder obsidian außenrum packt dann
hier diesmal komplett glasscheiben und
matt stone unter 1 sinken und das
laufband ist das wo ihr hier meine
arbeit seht und zwar da brauchen wir
auch ein tages lichtsensor eisengitter
redstone zwei obsidian und zwei schwarze
teppich
so jetzt fragt euch erstmal die sehen so
aus als würden die jäger jeden moment
sterben ja das tun wir auch weil die
ziemlich am arbeiten sind ich kann nicht
das ganze mal zeigen wenn ich das gleich
mal selbst aufbau ich erkläre ich das
ganze noch mal ganz kurz und zwar jetzt
habe ich den apotheke.com kommt nein
lacht dich weg du bist ja egal ist jetzt
nach komme ich las in meinem leben ist
jetzt auch egal
und zwar sind kann ich hier entweder
wölfe also diese hunde teile also die
sind ja noch wölfe wenn man die noch
nicht gezähmt hat entweder wölfe oder
schweine draufpacken auf diese
laufbänder so das heißt ich eben das
laufband was ihr euch hier gezeigt habe
jetzt einfach dahin und packte dann tier
drauf und dann stellte hier ein höhen
konstrukteur in das mehr brauchte
eigentlich nicht um erstmal eure hülle
zu erzeugen eben eigentlich sollte diese
jetzt aufbauen
aber das ist vielleicht ein creative bin
et cetera pp ich kann es einfach
rechtsklick hier drauf machen
jetzt hätte die sich gut aufgebaut aber
na ja gut ich habe dir die hölle drin
ich zeige es euch gleich nochmal mich
das ganz kurz nachbau jedenfalls seht
ihr jetzt hier mich ihr habt mich auch
schon letzte woche bei den effekt ohne
maske gesehen also ihr seid jetzt mehr
hier ohne maske das ist erstmal weil die
maske erst dazu kommt also wenn ihr eine
macht
gehabt kommt die maske erst dazu wenn
ihr dann wirklich dieser clown seit das
ist bei mir ganz gut dass mein klon das
bin nicht ich
und dann haben wir hier die höhen
speicher die leuchten jetzt grün
ähnliche direktor kaputt mache leuchtet
der rot die arbeiten leuchtend grünen
weil ich ja auch noch fackeln hinter
stehen habe so ich las die fackeln als
einfach mal hinter weil jetzt grün sind
ich habe jetzt hier einen clown
dementsprechend kann ich jetzt hier
reihen laufen so ist wenn ich jetzt mit
meiner maus nach oben gehen steht - 182
272 wenn ich auf drei drücke bin ich bei
den koordinaten 382 und 270 jetzt fragt
euch 100 erreichen koordinaten ja ich
kann mich da mit der maus runter geht
einfach drücken dann bin ich auf
abbrechen
dass es hier wo dieser clown steht das
sind die koordinaten so das heißt damit
ist dieser clown gemeint sie sich hier
ein wenig nach links rechts gbr blabla
bin ich trotzdem auf diesem ringen nur
wenn ich halt wieder der mitte geht es
halt abrechnet je nach oben und jetzt
ich drücke einfach nur einmal und der
rest wird jetzt von selbst gemacht ich
werde jetzt hoch geschleudert wie
sonstwas kommen jetzt in den clown
wieder rein
zack bin da drin jetzt bin ich quasi
hier drin die arbeiten jetzt alle nicht
welche drin bin ich kann es wieder raus
laufen dann arbeiten sie wieder türke zu
ich kann jetzt einmal recht machen und
jetzt wird mainz kenia aufgebaut
das geht eigentlich relativ schnell ich
am besten jetzt wenn ich jetzt hier noch
so ein tierchen hätte ich immer noch ein
schwein draufpacken überall mal eben
schweine drauf damit ich die hier damit
ich die arbeit damit ich das hier mal
einheitlich habe also müsste richtig
drauf machen wie das aufgebaut und das
soll jetzt so aussehen wie man es ging
also in ihrer fans gehen und da soll
jetzt mehr oder weniger mainz kinder
aufgebaut werden das geht schon relativ
schnell wenn man viel schweine da hat
ich hab ich das ganze jetzt aber zeige
ich baue das jetzt mal ganz kurz hier so
auf und zwar erstmal den konstrukteur
war das laufband brach ich dann machen
wir hier ein laufband so was jetzt
müssen wir so hinsetzen es müssen schon
jetzt packe ich mal ein schwein drauf
das läuft jetzt ganz normal relativ
langsam im vergleich zu den anderen
zurück jetzt mal drauf jetzt baut der
sich auf und das geht halt auch sehr
sehr langsam seht blog blog blog so ihr
blog blog blog blog blog blog blog blog
weshalb vier schweine sind es gibt
vielfach so schnell das heißt wenn ich
jetzt hier noch mehr dran stelle so ihr
seht jetzt geht das ungefähr so schnell
wer jetzt noch mehr einsätze geht das
ganze halt viel viel schneller mainboard
sich viel schneller auf da ich im
creative bin kann ich einfach machen und
zack und hab mir neue klone und hier
habe ich auch schon ein clown drin
stehen das ist so quasi wie ein remis
mit seinen verschiedenen anzügen so das
sind erstmal die sache wenn ich jetzt
quasi ich hier rein laufe während der
sich hier zwei skills zwei cloning teile
weil ich jetzt einmal den i hab der
obere hier der hier den ihr da oben seht
der jetzt ein bisschen größer wird hier
der da oben der hier ein ganz klein
bisschen größer
das ist der der rechts von mir steht
also wenn ihr gerade die facetime seht
da steht der ja ich glaube dass falls
richtig so der andere ist der hier das
heißt wenn jetzt auf den anderen drauf
clique wichtig wieder nach oben und
gehen diese andere cloning sache
rheinufer und das ist unglaublich und
außerdem wenn ich jetzt hier zum
beispiel einen schneemann inventar habe
und ich geh jetzt mal hier eben rein und
ich kann jetzt außerdem wieder in den
anderen reihen und zwar gehe ich jetzt
mal welche koordinaten nicht gerade ich
kenne zum beispiel hier draufklicken wer
es geht nach oben
und jetzt komme ich in den anderen clown
rein und jetzt habe ich hier wieder ein
inventar von vorhin also wohl natürlich
ein laufband höhlen konstrukteur
blablabla wenn ich jetzt wieder hier
rein gehe und ich klicke jetzt hier
dann müsste ich rein theoretisch in die
mittlere ach ja ganz rechts ganz rechts
bestimmt so und jetzt bin ich gegen
rechts trend heißt eines immer leer
damit ich da rein laufen cannoli ist
außerdem drauf gedrückt und es gibt auch
noch sachen dass wenn man stur wenn ich
ganz normal sterben ist es ja so mag ich
bin tot
allerdings ihr habt rad gesehen da war
meine seele die ist da so mein körper
ist also komplett weg gegangen und jetzt
bin ich hier wieder drin in dem typen
das ist ganz geil und zwar wenn ihr eine
höhle seit beispielsweise also jetzt im
survival finden ist es eigentlich nur
sinnvoll in der höhle weil die items
seiten sind trotzdem pack also die liga
trotzdem rom ihr seid nur hat kein tod
dann ist es ganz cool in der höhle wenn
in der höhle irgendwo seit und dann
denkt dass so viele und ich hab gar
keine blöcke mit dabei
brauch ich mir doch lieber mal so eine
komplizierte base hierauf mit den höhlen
speichern
und wenn ich dann sterben damit ich
direkt wieder in der höhle die können
natürlich auch einfach im bett bound
aber naja so dass einzig coole ist halt
daran dass er nicht sterben könnt wenn
ihr im hardcore mode zeit im hardcore
mode ist es so wenn man stirbt ist die
welt weg allerdings wenn ich jetzt so
sterbe ich glaube ich bin jetzt in
anderen so ihr seht meine tag mein
körper ist da quasi auseinandergefallen
jetzt gehe ich zurück in diese ganz
linke kammer und bin jetzt wieder diese
personen hier
das heißt im hardcore mode wenn ihr
immer 23 seit wir dem rat combo 10 von
diesem gehören kanistern eigentlich
theoretisch machen
ich weiß nicht wieso relativ egal müssen
jetzt halt alle bauern mit redstone weil
sonst die teile rot so dass wir können
jetzt quasi so viele klone immer
erzeugen
ich könnte jetzt hier so machen dann
gehe ich jetzt rein dann gehe ich in den
oberen so ich könnte jetzt hier so viele
klone von mir erzeugen dass sich quasi
wenn alles voll ist zehnmal sterben
könnte im hardcore mode dass ich immer
wieder wiederbelebt werden da teils
quasi wenn ihr diesem ort installiert
und die spielt hardcore würde ich mir
direkt sowas bauen dass ihr quasi wenn
ihr einmal stirbt das sie dann quasi an
sein limit up zu augen ich bin einmal
gestoppt jetzt darf ich noch drei mal
sterben nur noch zwei andere clown kann
es da mehr ab so was halt nach dem motto
und das wäre ganz cool für irgendwie ich
weiß es nicht
für wasser fallen bestimmt coole ideen
ein die mod an sich ist auch sehr sehr
geil wenn ich irgendwas vergessen habe
vorzustellen
sollte eigentlich alles dabei gewesen
sein ich kann euch das ganze noch leben
im netz zeigen habe ich mich auch im
vorbereitet so manch auch im recht ich
drauf kann ich auch eben irgendwo rein
gehen sie jetzt einerseits hier oben
gerade ein prozent das ist das im netz
der ist nämlich gerade fertig geworden
also da steht immer ein prozent im
creative blablabla ich glaub ich wieder
ist es viel zu viel input von mir hört
einfach zu voll durch einen dabei und da
ist alles gut ich kann jetzt hier im
netter natürlich einerseits durch den
leser durch nachts raus und jetzt liege
ich wieder in den rhein in meinen clown
was sich allerdings auch kern ist jetzt
einfach mal warten
in over world gehen ich fliege hier raus
und kaum einer normalen welt wieder an
es ist zwar alles noch ein bisschen
verbuggt ihr habt gesehen ich war grade
irgendwie im dschungel ich habe keine
ahnung vielleicht ist es die riesige
minecraft kugel und ich bin da auf der
anderen seite dann gewesen das genau
gleich kann ich halt doch einfach wieder
hier rein gehen und dann seht ihr mal
darunter die koordinaten never never was
ich jetzt mal nett weil ich im jahr zwei
kleine von mir habe ich müsste jetzt in
den rechten glaube ich reinkommen ja ich
bin im rechten also im rechten so meine
lieben freunde das ist die qualifikation
ist kommt nicht richtig geile sachen
auch im netz will meine waren fliegen
rannte ich sterbe ich flieg nach irgend
zu gott sagt hey du ich hab clown ich
bin nicht tot und fall wieder nach unten
das auf jeden fall sehr nice und es geht
halt desto langsamer desto weniger
schwein ich halt drauf und das heißt
wenn ich jetzt zwei von runter schlag so
sehr sehr langsam ich gar keine habe
passiert dementsprechend nichts es geht
mit wölfen und schwein nicht wiederholen
ich gerade du bist gestorben
ich nenne ich gut meine lieben freunde
und zwar das ist eine modifikation die
halt naja das heißt ich muss mich da
viel drauf vorbereiten das war war auf
jeden fall eine coole modifikation
wollte ich jetzt mal eben sagen
und zwar habe ich also ein neues
rätsel mehr oder weniger und zwar immer
am ende einer mod vorstellung oder
manchmal so am ende der videos werde ich
euch ein geheimnisvoller ein
geheimnisvolles geräusch sagen das heißt
wenn wir bis zum ende dran bleibt kann
es sein dass eure kommentare das nächste
mal ins nächste video kommt weil ich
mache ich jetzt ein geräusch vor moment
moment moment moment ich mache ich jetzt
ein geräusch vor und ihr müsst jetzt
erraten was das für ein geräusch ist ich
mache das jetzt mal einmalig ich weiß
nicht ob sie das cool findet ihr müsst
erraten was das für ein geräusch ist und
verrät den kommentar wenn ich dann halt
im nächsten video und erstmal ganz
normal des videos jetzt vorbei das
hätten alle die jetzt ist geheimnisvolle
geräusche nicht mehr mit kriegen wollen
geht jetzt geht los und zwar ein
geheimnisvoller geräusch erwartet was es
ist was war das ich mach's nochmal
vielleicht auch einmal von der anderen
neben von anderer seite nicht dann seht
ihr das nochmal noch einmal was würdet
ihr rad machte es ist ich glaube keiner
kommt drauf aber naja gut freunde das
was von der mod vorstellen ich hoffe
euch als gefallen wenn ja dann lass
bitte eine daumen einen daumen nach oben
was bitte eine positive bewertung da das
zeigt mir dass euch gefallen hatte sich
mehrmals machen soll könnt mir auch noch
schreiben die ich vorstellen soll und
dann würde ich sagen sind beim nächsten
mal wieder voll rein macht school einen
wunderschönen tag und